Il m'arrive de rencontrer parfois d'autres créateurs de vidéos sur Internet
Des youtubeurs par exemple on discute et je leurs dis que je suis abonné à ta chaine j'aime beaucoup et les gens me disent
" Ah bon ah j'y crois pas c'est pas possible"
Comme si j'avais pas le droit de m'abonner aux chaînes des autres
Franchement, je regarde vidéos de plein de créateurs différents je suis abonné à une centaine de chaînes
Et je me suis suis dit que se serait pas mal que je vous parle d'une dizaine de chaînes on va dire qui me tiennent à coeur
Extrême Warning ,vous n'allez pas retrouver les chaînes YouTube de potes dans ce que je vais vous raconter
Il n'y aura pas malheureusement Squeezie, Mcfly & Carlito, Norman, Yvick qui vous voulez ça c'est acquis
Là je vais vous parler de trucs un peu plus obscures
Un peu plus personnels aussi peut-être qu'il y a des chaînes qui vont pas trop vous parlez, moi c'est ma cam à 1000% c'est des  chaînes qui viennent du coeur
C'est parti on va commencer !
Chaine de malek
Hop on commence avec Malek .C'est  quelque qu'un qui travaille dans l'animation Voilà Qui fait des dessins animés
Sur sa chaîne youtube, il a deux formats qui sont énormes d'abord il a des rap battle entre personnages de fictions
Par exemple entre Golden Freezer et Astérix Début du rap :
"Tu devrais demander a Jules comment on traite ses petits legionnaires 59 ans de pression on est chaud retourne dans ton frigidaire "
C'est dingue parce que bah déjà y'a le rap  pour faire la chanson tout ça l'écrire c'est génial
Et le dessin animé, il est mortel
Franchement c'est trop ouf ça dure pas longtemps mais ça me rend dingue c'est ce qui est un peu cartonné au début
Et maintenant il a un deuxième format qui est si telle série était un dessin animé japonais
Il fait un générique d'animé japonais mais version Game of Thrones c'est mortel, il a fait aussi si Rick & Morty était un animé japonais
C'est génial
Franchement,on a l'impression que ça existe quoi Les vidéos font à chaque fois plusieurs millions de vues tellement c'est que c'est ouf
Mais il n'a pas tant d'abonnés que ça on peut réparer ça
Et en plus Malek a subi une petite injustice d'Internet
C'est que ses vidéos se font très régulièrement repomper par des pages facebook ou twitter ou ce que vous voulez sans citer la source
Plutot, que de mettre ça sur votre page facebook ou twitter ou chepas quoi
Partager le lien ! C'est bien aussi !
Voilà j'essaye un peu de rétablir sa justice
Aller voir la chaine de Malek c'est trop drole
Il sort peu de vidéo mais elles sont voilà
Thomas Romain
Alors qui est Thomas Romain c'est quelque qu'un qui travaille également dans l'animation
Décidement, qui vit au Japon et qui a travaillé dans des studios d'animations japonaises
Et Thomas, il a un projet un peu fou qu'il poste sur sa chaine youtube
Il demande à ses enfants qui ont je n'sais pas une dizaines d'années De dessiner des monstres un peu stylés un peu farfelu
Et lui, il les redessine en version trop stylé Et il montre ça en vidéo
Donc,bah il y a ses enfants qu'ils montrent un petit peu le dessin qu'ils expliquent  ce que veut dire quoi, les couleurs qu'ils utilisent
Et ensuite,il y a Thomas qui redessine tous ça qui rajoute de l'aquarelle  Il rajoute forcément sa patte il ajoute des détails et il essaye  en tous cas d'etre le plus fidèle possible aux dessins de ses enfants
Et je trouve ça trop cool !
Et si vous etes des gros gros fan de son travail et de se projet là il a sortis aussi un livre
Qui est un receuil de tous les dessins de ses enfants  avec ses dessins à lui  moi ça me parle à mille pour cent parce que voilà c'est un projet de dessins c'est en vidéos il y a des astuces  avec ses enfants
je trouve ça trop cool !
Winter Gahtane
musicien qui s'appelle martin qui a eu à un projet assez dingue il ya de ça quelques années il a fabriqué une machine
une machine avec des billes qui fait de la musique vous êtes peut-être déjà vu cette vidéo s'appelle la marbre en chine
Cette vidéo avait beaucoup pesé parce que c'était absolument dingue de faire une musique aussi stylée avec
juste une machine qui tourne et débit qui tombait et lui qui actionne des leviers c'est absolument d'électro et il s'est mis dans la tête de
fabriquer une version
supérieure de sa marble machines et du coup toutes les semaines ils postent des vidéos
pour expliquer comment il fabrique cette pièce là comment ils améliorent cette partie là ça peut être des choix artistiques
des choix de matériaux il fait usines et ses pièces en aluminium
par dégâts chez paou qui on voit par la poste et ils testent la vitesse de chute d'une bille des systèmes dément pour faire remonter
débit bref il est parti dans un délire c'est ouf s'il passe pas loin de paris un jour j'irai le voir en concert
parce que ça a l'air d'être du très très lourd maintenant je vais vous parler de deux chaînes en même temps pourquoi en même temps
c'est parce qu'en fait j'ai participé récemment à chacun de leurs projets yes vous aime et inherent net
j'espère que vous connaissez ces deux chaînes donc d'un côté nous avons yes vous aime un
collectif de comédiens ils font sur internet pas mal de parodies des parodies d'émissions télé ils ont parodié les petites vidéos brut bons mois en
faut savoir qu'à la base et j'étais dans la rue pour défendre les bagnoles
bons ils ont fini par rouler dessus par
odile et vidéos youtube eux les singes ou trop bien et a plein d'idées et là ils ont tourné une web série qui vont porter
sur leur chaîne youtube qui s'appelle abonne toi ou c'est l'histoire du collectif yes vous m qui va essayer de gagner de plus en plus
d'abonnés et ils m'ont fait participer à leur petite série j'ai hâte que ça sorte je pense que c'est pourtant pas très très longtemps et
d'un autre côté nous avons internet c'est comme jeter renaître mais sans le thé une chaîne youtube créée par benoît blanc et
mathias gear big
benoît blanc que vous avez vu par exemple dans les vidéos de mcfly carlito c'est lui qui a fait le juge du dernier youtube warrior
par exemple et ces gars là c'est des fous ils font de l'humour vraiment absurde ils font une sorte de fausse interview il faut un
peu tout et n'importe quoi va porter en short ou en grèce votre veste
on est sur scène
ben oui forcément hélas leur nouveau projet et j'étais très content de participer à ça ça s'appelle romans photos et ils font une
aventure dans un espace de coworking avec des personnages un peu fou sauf que les gens ne bougent pas comme dans un roman photo
elle flirte avec marcus
au calme je vous laisse découvrir romans photos mais aussi toutes leurs autres vidéos ya ce 12ème et internet c'est vraiment deux chaînes
français n'a pas encore explosé mais ça mérite à mon sens c'est de l'absurde
c'est du réfléchi quand même c'est de l'intelligence et du travail c'est la qualité c'est tout ce que j'aime bien dans une vidéo youtube
simone giertz
On reste dans l'absurde avec la chaîne youtube de simone
voilà je sais pas comment prononcer son nom de famille donc on va juste l'appeler simone qui est une suédoise qui fabrique des robots
absolument débile c'est des robots qui ont une utilité mais sont fabriqués de sorte à ce que ça parte en vrille et un de ses
grands succès c'est par exemple
son réveil mais débattre à travailler elle a fait aussi une machine pour s'essuyer les fesses avec une perceuse coton mot dire que c'est peut-être
un peu trop efficace une machine pour se brosser les dents une machine pour boire des sous et
heureusement ça ne marche jamais c'est ça finalement sa spécialité petite précision les vidéos sont en anglais mais pas besoin
de parler anglais pour voir une machine qui ne fonctionne pas et puis c'est très souvent sous titré ce qui est aussi fascinant sa vie
n'a aucun sens
elle a vécu dans un bateau elle a participé à des tournages de séries en chine parce qu'elle parle un petit peu chinois sa voiture
ressemble un fromage frais c'est un peu un personnage de dessin animé on a l'impression
malheureusement elle a sorti deux vidéos récemment parce qu'en fait elle a eu une tumeur au cerveau s est fait opérer
visiblement voilà les nouvelles sont pas encore très bonne donc moi je lui souhaite un très bon rétablissement
beaucoup de forces à simone merci pour ce que tu fais courage thomas gauthier
vous l'avez peut-être déjà vu dans mon tour du monde parce qu'il m'a accueilli à
montréal voilà dans sa ville thomas gautier vient du québec et il est sur youtube depuis très très longtemps
depuis aussi longtemps que moi il me semble j'ai l'impression d'être une personne âgée quand je dis ça
Thomas Gauthier il a fait toutes sortes de vidéos dans des formats très différents et va faire une petite fiction avec son colloque qui va
te faire des vidéos sur n'importe quel thème
c'est ça que j'aime bien c'est qu'il a beaucoup de liberté surtout c'est très drôle récemment il a fait par exemple à six mois qui
s'appelle tabou il revient sur
des petites vidéos des faits de société en quelque sorte si vous avez regardé les nouvelles dans les cinq dernières années vous savez probablement déjà
qu'il ya des monstruosités
se passe partout autour du globe et lui donne son avis là dedans il met ça en perspective avec des petits concept de philosophie et
à la fin ça se termine par une petite chanson hyper stylé pour sauver la terre pour de bon
Y'a pas 10 000 solution
faire un suicide collectif
Se poignarder avec des canifs il explique aussi des moments de l'histoire un peu pour les jeunes  c'est un peu débile mais c'est vraiment géniale
il fait aussi des web-séries bref il a vraiment plein de cordes à son arc je suis un des premiers
abonnés de thomas gautier vraiment je
découvrais sad il ya très longtemps et je suis toujours très fidèle et merci de m'avoir accueilli dans ta ville formidable qu'est montréal
franchement c'est toujours d'une grande qualité tout en étant original et drôle
j'achète quoi là on a un concept exceptionnel c'est ma came à fond. Kekeflipnote
ça manquait un peu d'animation on y retourne avec la chaîne youtube de kéké qui s'appelle le kevin qui est aussi quelqu'un qui travaille dans
l'animation kéké alors là c'est un délire
il crée des animations sur sa Nintendo ds il sait faire d'autres choses mais ça c'est quand même sa spécialité il fait des courtes vidéos avec des
animaux qui y danse ou qui vivent des petites aventures souvent c'est sur des petites musiques style et c'est improbable c'est trop mignon c'est trop
bien fait on sent toute son âme dans ces petites vidéos ça que j'aime bien voilà ça lui ressemble à 1000% dès que ça sort
je clique j'adore montre moi des animaux qui dansent une baguette et un renard qui font win-win je veux voir ça ça me rend fou
On retourne au japon ça s'appelle archipel parce que le japon est un archipel c'est à dire un ensemble
d'îles cette chaîne youtube publie des reportages sur des artistes japonais mais aussi un petit peu d'autres choses ils ont commencé avec un format qui
est mortelle qui s'appelle tokotoko qui suit des artistes japonais qui explique un petit peu leur art mais aussi
les lieux où ils vont régulièrement et moi je trouve ça passionnant il va avoir des musiciens des concepteurs de jeux vidéo des dessinateurs des
animateurs des stylistes des sculpteurs de figurines bref pleins d'artistes du japon maison de plus en plus de formats par exemple pour je sais pas
moi parler de cuisine ou alors un nouveau lieu
bref c'est trop stylé c'est hyper intéressant c'est trop beau c'est sous titrée en français bref ne manquait rien
archipel c'est dans mon top 10 direct scinema
vous aimez le cinéma
moi j'aime beaucoup le cinéma connaissez-vous cinéma avec un s au début c'est une chaîne YouTube qui parle de science et de cinéma
le créateur de cette chaîne qui s'appelle jean baptiste va prendre une thématique dans le cinéma qui va essayer de d'expliquer par la science par
exemple il vient de sortir là ya pas longtemps est ce que c'est possible de créer de l'énergie
avec des cris des enfants par rapport au film monstres et compagnie de pixar c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'ils vont encore aux enfants pour remplir de
l'énergie pour la vie ou alors il a parlé de mécanique des fluides comme ça c'est fait pas avant d'aimer c'est absolument ouf pour expliquer
comment ils ont réussi à faire de
l'eau hyper réaliste dans pirates des caraïbes c'est drôle c'est bien fait franchement il y a plein de graphisme de montage c'est ouf
le travail sur cette chaîne j'adore l'eau
C'est le genre de vidéo qui donne envie de s'intéresser au cinéma ou à la science et qui donne envie de revoir des films et
qui te fait rire
putain on va reparler du japon je suis désolé pour ceux qui ne sont pas sensibles au japon comme je le suis moi ce top
n'a aucun sens mais je suis désolé je suis obligé de vous parler des publicités japonaises les
publicités japonais c'est un délire de gens qui consomment de la drogue qui font une publicité
il ya des gens qui sont drogués
avec cette publicité ça n'a pas de sens je trouve ça tellement drôle et intéressant et très très bizarre
du coup il ya des chaînes youtube qui compile des publicités japonaises toutes les semaines tous les mois vous avez des publicités japonaises en vrac
comme ça pendant dix minutes et tu dis waouh qu'est ce qui m'arrive ça me fait voyager j'ai l'impression de retourner au japon
si vous voulez des nouvelles sensations c'est pas mal. freddy gladieux vous avez peut-être déjà vu ces vidéos
absolument débile à freddy il a fait des petites vidéos qui sont devenus assez connu par exemple le
soldat est là qui envoie de la viande vous avez déjà vu ça
qu'est ce que tu fais là fait les voix aussi pendant un match de football bat pour pas mal travaillé
Sur deux papas ils aiment bien interagir avec d'autres vidéos ou les décortiquer mais parfois il va dans des délires qui n'ont plus aucun sens
par exemple y décortique les sports aux jeux olympiques d'hiver ski et les tons qu'est-ce qui fait il en équilibre skis sur les mains
je comprends pas il est surtout très actif sur instagram et c'est stories je savais pas qu'on pouvait dire autant de conneries dans la journée
je sais qu'aujourd'hui il travaille avec ivy qu'avec des gens comme ça parce qu'il a beaucoup de talent mais rld est très drôle donc du
coup j'ai hâte de découvrir un peu toutes ces prochaines vidéos à notre ami freddy gladieux c'est oui
et voilà c'est la fin d'une petite sélection de dix chaînes que j'aime particulièrement
j'espère que vous avez fait un petit peu des découvertes et
peut-être des coups de coeur de votre part aussi vous allez pouvoir vous abonner à toutes ces chaînes là vous avez pas mal de dos
liens dans la description dans tous les cas il ya un peu tout et n'importe quoi dans cette liste de chaînes youtube il y a quand
même un point commun c'est qu'en fait ils ne publient pas très très
régulièrement sur youtube
et c'est vrai qu'il ya une grosse tendance sur internet a publié de plus en plus de contenu mais pour faire du contenu original
ou de qualité ça peut prendre du temps je mets aussi en lien un
petit best-of de la chaîne les
internettes qui met en avant les créatrices sur youtube ce qui a très peu de femmes s'est lui-même dans ce classement il n'y a que
simone malheureusement voilà c'est un petit peu tout ce que j'avais à dire aujourd'hui j'espère que vous avez fait des petites découvertes et que ça
vous appelez moi je vous dis à très vite sur internet pour une prochaine vidéo au revoir
Musique